There's this political parable about Hillary Clinton that made the rounds during the primaries this year, a parable with many layers to it. One of our contributors, Jack Hitt, wrote about this recently for the New Republic.
今年初选期间，政界流传着一则关于希拉里·克林顿的寓言，这则寓言有着多重含义。我们的撰稿人之一杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）最近在《新共和》杂志上对此进行了报道。
Elizabeth Warren is the person who tells this story. So this goes all the way back to the late 90s when Bill Clinton was still in office.
伊丽莎白·沃伦（Elizabeth Warren）是讲这个故事的人。故事要追溯到90年代末，当时比尔·克林顿还在任。
Hillary Clinton was First Lady. Elizabeth Warren wasn't a senator yet. She was a law professor at Harvard.
希拉里·克林顿当时是第一夫人。伊丽莎白·沃伦还不是参议员，她是哈佛大学的法学教授。
And she had written, I think, an op-ed piece about this one bankruptcy bill. And Warren tells the story of the First Lady making contact. And they sat down. And she said, it was just amazing talking to Hillary Clinton.
我想当时她写了一篇关于某项破产法案的评论文章。沃伦讲述了第一夫人与她联系的故事。她们坐下来谈了谈。她说，与希拉里·克林顿交谈真是太棒了。
And just the two of us. They closed the door. Mrs. Clinton sits down. We have hamburgers and french fries.
当时只有我们两个人。她们关上了门。克林顿夫人坐了下来。我们吃了汉堡包和炸薯条。
You tutor her.
你辅导了她。
This is Elizabeth Warren telling the story to Bill Moyers on television in 2004. One of the problems with this bill, she explained, is that if a man went bankrupt, he would have to pay off his credit card companies and his banks before he would pay off an ex-wife or child support and alimony. She explained this to Moyers.
这是伊丽莎白·沃伦2004年在电视上对比尔·莫耶斯（Bill Moyers）讲述的故事。她解释说，该法案的问题之一是，如果一个人破产了，他必须先偿还信用卡公司和银行的钱，然后才能支付前妻的赡养费或子女抚养费。她向莫耶斯解释了这一点。
And I got to tell you, I never had a smarter student. Quick, right to the heart of it. I go over the law. It's a complex law. Went over the economics, showed her the graphs, showed her the charts. And she got it. Within 20 minutes, she could play where the rest of it would come. Well then, that will mean this part's happened. That will mean this is happening.
我得告诉你，我从未教过比她更聪明的学生。反应很快，直击要害。我讲解了这项法律。这是一部复杂的法律。我讲了经济学，给她看了图表，给她看了数据。她全懂了。20分钟内，她就能推导出后续的影响。好吧，这意味着这部分会发生。这意味着那部分正在发生。
And she got right to the heart of it, totally understood it, and went back and convinced Bill to veto this bankruptcy bill.
她直击要害，完全理解了，并回去说服比尔否决了这项破产法案。
Warren said Bill Clinton had been planning on signing the bill. She credits Hillary with turning him around.
沃伦说比尔·克林顿本来打算签署该法案。她将他的回心转意归功于希拉里。
And that's the Hillary that we all recognize, if you've read any of the magazine bios of her that go all the way back to college, the valedictorian, the A-plus student, the woman who does her homework, figures it out, and has the best understanding. But then, Warren tells a second part to the story.
如果你读过任何关于她的杂志传记，从大学时的告别演说致辞人、全A学生、那个做作业、钻研问题并拥有最深刻理解力的女人开始，这就是我们大家都认识的希拉里。但随后，沃伦又讲了故事的第二部分。
This part happens just a few months after the bill is vetoed. It's 2001, Clinton is no longer the First Lady.
这部分发生在法案被否决几个月后。那是2001年，克林顿已经不再是第一夫人了。
So this time, she's a United States senator. She's been elected. A lot of her campaign money came from Wall Street, as Warren points out when she tells this story.
所以这一次，她是美国参议员了。她当选了。正如沃伦在讲这个故事时所指出的，她的竞选资金很大一部分来自华尔街。
And one of the first bills that came up after she was Senator Clinton was the bankruptcy bill. This is a bill that's like a vampire. It will not die. There's a lot of money behind it. And it--
希拉里当选参议员后提出的首批法案之一就是破产法案。这是一个像吸血鬼一样的法案。它怎么也死不了。背后有大量的资金。而且它……
And Bill, her husband, had vetoed.
而她的丈夫比尔曾否决过它。
Her husband had vetoed it very much at her urging.
她的丈夫正是在她的极力催促下否决了它。
And?
然后呢？
She voted in favor of it.
她投票支持它。
And of course, that's the Hillary that is often described as the opportunist, the woman who will do anything to keep power.
当然，这就是那个常被描述为机会主义者的希拉里，那个为了保住权力不惜一切代价的女人。
The schemer.
阴谋家。
Yeah, the captive of Wall Street.
是的，华尔街的俘虏。
But then, there's yet another turn to the story. And that's in Hillary Clinton's version of the story. Hillary Clinton says, yes. She voted for the bill. But she did not do that to suck up to Wall Street. She says--
但随后，故事又有了另一个转折。那是希拉里·克林顿的版本。希拉里·克林顿说，是的。她投了赞成票。但她这样做不是为了讨好华尔街。她说……
She had quietly lobbied to insert language that would protect the vulnerable populations that Elizabeth Warren had warned her about, like single moms.
她曾私下游说加入保护弱势群体的措辞，这些群体正是伊丽莎白·沃伦警告过她的，比如单身母亲。
I took that on. And I went to the floor. And I buttonholed the Democrats and the Republicans who were leading that bill. I said, you can't do this. You--
我承担了这项工作。我来到议会大厅。我私下说服了领导该法案的民主党人和共和党人。我说，你们不能这样做。你们……
And so, when you hear this version of the story, then you see, oh yes. Right. Well, this is the Hillary Clinton that many liberal commentators love to talk about, the really smart, sharp, the legislator, the one who understands that so many of these legal battles, these legislative battles, happen inside the parentheses of some footnote somewhere, a detail-oriented, shrewd--
所以，当你听到这个版本的故事情节时，你会想，哦，是的。对。好吧，这就是许多自由派评论员喜欢谈论的希拉里·克林顿，那个非常聪明、敏锐的立法者，那个明白许多法律斗争、立法斗争都发生在某个脚注括号里的细节导向型、精明的……
In this version of the story, Hillary gets to have her cake and eat it too. When she votes for the bill, it pleases Wall Street. When she adds the provision for divorced moms, it pleases her liberal base. Everybody's happy. But there is yet one last turn to the screw. In 2005, the bill comes up yet again in the Senate. It still has not become law. And this time, the protections that Clinton had fought for, for mothers and other vulnerable populations, those were not in the bill.
在这个故事版本中，希拉里鱼与熊掌兼得。当她为法案投票时，她讨好了华尔街。当她为离婚母亲增加条款时，她讨好了她的自由派基础。每个人都很高兴。但故事还有最后一个转折。2005年，该法案再次提交参议院。它仍然没有成为法律。而这一次，克林顿曾为母亲和其他弱势群体争取的保护条款，都没有出现在法案中。
So there's no way out for her on this one. She has to declare her side, who she's really defending in Congress, Wall Street or these vulnerable populations that elect her to office.
所以她这次没路可退了。她必须表明立场，她在国会真正捍卫的是谁，是华尔街，还是选她上台的那些弱势群体。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
And what happens? Bill is in the hospital for something. And she goes to his bedside and claims that she can't be present for the vote in Congress. Essentially she goes AWOL from the decision and is not there to vote either way.
结果怎么样？比尔因为某些原因住院了。她去床边探望他，声称自己无法出席国会的投票。本质上，她从决策中脱岗了，没去投票。
She does issue a statement saying that she's against the bill. But she doesn't actually vote against the bill. It passes.
她确实发表声明说她反对该法案。但她实际上并没有对法案投反对票。它通过了。
And this is the Hillary that drives a lot of people insane. Because this one seems even more Machiavellian, whatever it takes to save my skin.
这就是让很多人抓狂的希拉里。因为这看起来甚至更马基雅维利，为了保全自己不择手段。
In his article, Jack had list the different Hillarys that we see in different stories about her. There's the A-student, the opportunist. There's the mastermind, the rat-fink, the pragmatist, the truth-twister.
在文章中，杰克列出了我们在不同故事中看到的不同的希拉里。有全A学生，机会主义者。有策划者、告密者、务实者、歪曲事实者。
Almost any story you hear about Hillary, you can kind of break down these various Hillarys in that story. We run across her in all of these variations all the time.
你听到的几乎任何关于希拉里的故事，你都可以在其中分解出这些不同的希拉里。我们一直都在这些变体中遇见她。
I have to say, one of the things with Hillary is that she can seem like all of these Hillarys at once sometimes. And then, occasionally, you get a glimpse of a side of Hillary Clinton that is none of those, that doesn't fit any of the regular pictures we have of her. We have a story like that for you today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
我不得不说，希拉里的一点是，她有时看起来像所有这些希拉里的集合体。然后，偶尔，你会瞥见希拉里·克林顿不属于其中任何一种的一面，这一面不符合我们对她的任何常规描述。今天我们有一个这样的故事要讲给你听。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Here's what we're going to do on today's program. We have this story about Hillary Clinton that, when I saw it, I feel like it gave me a picture of her that-- first of all, it comes from completely credible sources, FBI interviews, in fact. And it painted a very different picture from what we have all been hearing from both sides in this election.
今天节目我们要讲的是：我们有一个关于希拉里·克林顿的故事，当我看到它时，我觉得它给了我一张她的肖像，首先，它来自完全可靠的消息来源，实际上是联邦调查局（FBI）的访谈记录。它描绘的画面与我们在这次选举中双方听到的完全不同。
And then, after that story, all of us here at our show all thought, OK, everybody is so tired of this election and so stressed out on the left and the right-- like, everyone is so freaked out. What's going to happen if their candidate loses? We thought, here at our show, let's just have something funny on the radio and on the internet. So we're going to have that too. Stay with us.
在那之后，我们节目组的所有人都想，好吧，大家对这次选举已经非常厌倦，左派和右派都倍感压力——每个人都快崩溃了。如果他们的候选人输了会怎样？我们想，不如在广播和互联网上放点有趣的东西。所以我们也要这么做。留下来。
Serve or Be Served-- so Hillary Clinton's polling numbers took a dive this week, of course, after FBI Director James Comey said agents would be reviewing more of her e-mails. There are two basic stories out there about Hillary Clinton's e-mails and her decision to use a private server for her e-mails when she was Secretary of State. The Clinton version of what happened is that she made a mistake. There's nothing in those e-mails. This is her enemies making a lot of noise about nothing.
服务还是被服务——当然，在FBI局长詹姆斯·科米（James Comey）表示特工将审查更多她的电子邮件后，希拉里·克林顿的民调数据本周暴跌。关于希拉里·克林顿的电子邮件以及她担任国务卿时决定使用私人服务器处理邮件，外界主要有两种说法。克林顿的版本是她犯了一个错误。那些邮件里什么都没有。这是她的敌人在无事生非。
The Trump version of what happened is that she's a criminal and that she will be prosecuted, she will serve time over those e-mails and the way she's handled them. This was her using a private server to keep secrets from the American people. But I was really struck a few weeks ago reading this article on Politico. If you don't know Politico, it's a nonpartisan political news site and magazine.
特朗普的版本是她是个罪犯，她会因为这些邮件以及她处理邮件的方式而被起诉、坐牢。这是她使用私人服务器向美国人民隐瞒秘密。但我几周前读到《政治报》（Politico）上的这篇文章时，真的深受震撼。如果你不知道《政治报》，它是一个无党派的政治新闻网站和杂志。
And this article told a history of the e-mails that, for all the commotion about these e-mails over this past year, I had never heard this. What they did was simple. After the FBI released its summaries of the interviews that its investigators did with Hillary Clinton and State Department officials and intel experts and CIA experts and some of Clinton's closest aides, a political writer named Garrett Graff read through the 247 pages of summaries.
这篇文章讲述了这些电子邮件的历史，尽管过去一年来围绕这些邮件闹得沸沸扬扬，但我从未听说过。他们做的事情很简单。在FBI发布了调查人员对希拉里·克林顿、国务院官员、情报专家、中央情报局专家以及克林顿一些核心助手进行访谈的总结后，一位名叫加勒特·格拉夫（Garrett Graff）的政治作家通读了这247页的摘要。
It's a public document. You can get a copy online yourself. But I think maybe only a handful of reporters have actually read through the entirety of it. And then, Garrett Graff put together an exhaustive and, frankly, very page-turney account of exactly what happened, according to what the FBI found.
这是一份公开文件。你自己可以在网上查到副本。但我认为可能只有少数记者真正通读了全部内容。然后，加勒特·格拉夫拼凑出一份详尽的，坦率地说，非常引人入胜的叙述，详细记录了FBI发现的究竟发生了什么。
That is, how Hillary Clinton and her aides ended up doing her e-mails this way. What were they thinking? How did this happen? How did she end up running her e-mail from a private server in the basement of her house, including e-mails with classified information on them? Garrett Graff talk to one of our producers, Sean Cole, about this. Here's Sean.
也就是说，希拉里·克林顿和她的助手最终是如何以这种方式处理她的电子邮件的。他们在想什么？这是怎么发生的？她是怎么最终在自家地下室用私人服务器处理电子邮件的，包括那些带有机密信息的邮件？加勒特·格拉夫与我们的一位制片人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）谈论了这个问题。这是肖恩。
Garrett Graff spent three days reading the interview summaries. He's been covering the FBI for almost a decade. And he's pored over a lot of documents like these. And his conclusion, after reading the 247 pages, is this. The way Hillary and her top aides dealt with her e-mails is indeed scandalous. It's just a totally different scandal than people thought.
加勒特·格拉夫花了三天时间阅读访谈摘要。他报道FBI新闻近十年了。他查阅过很多这样的文件。读完这247页后，他的结论是：希拉里和她的高层助手处理邮件的方式确实丑闻缠身。只是这与人们想象的完全是另一回事。
I think a lot of us thought that this was done out of sophistication. That it was done out of this very advanced Machiavellian understanding of federal records laws and advanced knowledge of computer technology. But by the time the FBI got done with all of these interviews, it becomes really clear it was actually done out of technological ignorance.
我想我们很多人都认为这是出于老练。这是出于对联邦记录法律的极高明、马基雅维利式的理解，以及对计算机技术的先进知识。但当FBI完成所有这些访谈时，很明显，这实际上是出于技术无知。
Garrett writes that the documents, quote, "depict less a sinister and carefully calculated effort to avoid transparency than a busy and uninterested executive who shows little comfort with even the basics of technology, working with a small, harried, inner circle of aides. Reading the FBI interviews," he writes," Clinton's team hardly seems organized enough to mount any sort of sinister cover up."
加勒特写道，这些文件“描述的不是一种阴险且精心策划的逃避透明度的企图，而是一个忙碌且对技术并不感兴趣的高管，她表现得对基本技术都不太适应，身边只有一小群惊慌失措的核心助手。阅读FBI的访谈，”他写道，“克林顿的团队似乎组织性太差，无法进行任何形式的阴险掩盖。”
So beginning at the beginning. When Hillary took over Secretary of State, she and her staff had to figure out how she would handle e-mail. Hillary had always checked her e-mail on a BlackBerry. And she requested a secure government-issued BlackBerry. But she was told she wouldn't be able to use her personal e-mail account on it. That wasn't allowed. And using government e-mail for personal stuff was discouraged.
让我们从头说起。当希拉里接任国务卿时，她和她的员工必须找出她该如何处理电子邮件。希拉里一直用黑莓（BlackBerry）手机查看邮件。她申请了一部安全的政府配发黑莓手机。但她被告知不能在上面使用个人电子邮件账户。这是不允许的。而且不鼓励在政府电邮上处理个人事务。
And if you remember, one of the first things Hillary Clinton said when this scandal broke in 2015 was, well, I didn't want to carry two devices. And everyone in Washington started laughing at that. Because most officials, most people in Washington, carry two or three devices.
如果你还记得，2015年这个丑闻曝光时，希拉里·克林顿说的第一件事就是，好吧，我不想携带两台设备。华盛顿的每个人都开始笑话这个说法。因为华盛顿的大多数官员，大多数人，都携带两到三台设备。
Because there are strict prohibitions against using government phones or computers to do political campaigning. So multiple devices is normal.
因为有严格的禁令禁止使用政府电话或电脑进行政治竞选活动。所以多台设备是常态。
But when we actually read through these documents, you can almost come away with a sense that that is actually why they did it, that Hillary seems to actually be a very persnickety technology user. She is not very comfortable with most technology, only liked to use a BlackBerry and, more specifically, only liked to use a specific type of increasingly older and more out-of-date BlackBerry.
但当我们通读这些文件时，你几乎可以得出结论，这确实是他们这么做的原因。希拉里似乎确实是一个非常挑剔的技术用户。她不太习惯大多数技术，只喜欢用黑莓手机，更具体地说，只喜欢用一种越来越老旧、过时的黑莓手机。
She doesn't know how to use a desktop computer. She--
她不知道怎么用台式电脑。她……
Wait, wait, wait. Back up. Back up. She doesn't know how to use a desktop computer.
等等，等等。倒回去。倒回去。她不知道怎么用台式电脑。
Hillary Clinton, the Democratic presidential nominee in 2016, does not know how to use a desktop computer, according to multiple sources interviewed by the FBI.
据FBI采访的多个消息来源称，2016年民主党总统候选人希拉里·克林顿不知道如何使用台式电脑。
How is that possible?
这怎么可能？
The short answer is, I don't know. I mean, I can get not knowing how to play an X-Box or a virtual reality machine or something like that.
简短的回答是，我不知道。我是说，我不懂怎么玩Xbox或者虚拟现实机之类的东西。
Right.
对。
But a desktop computer, this is literally the oldest piece of personal technology available to us today.
但台式电脑，这真的是我们今天能用到的最古老的个人技术设备了。
I looked into this. It's actually the abacus. At the same time, says Garrett, you have to think about where the Clintons were at the advent of the everyday internet. When Bill Clinton was elected in 1992, you could count the number of websites in the dozens. Bill himself didn't really properly use the internet until 1998. They just didn't live regular lives and never would again.
我研究过这个。其实是算盘。加勒特说，同时，你必须考虑克林顿夫妇在日常互联网出现时所处的阶段。1992年比尔·克林顿当选时，你可以用两位数数出网站的数量。比尔本人直到1998年才真正开始使用互联网。他们只是没有过上正常的生活，以后也永远不会了。
When Hillary became Secretary of State, she asked one of her predecessors, Colin Powell, how he dealt with e-mail. He wrote to her, quote, "I didn't have a BlackBerry. What I did do was have a personal computer that was hooked up to a private phone line--" sounds ancient-- --"so I could communicate with a wide range of friends directly without it going through the State Department's servers. I even used it to do business with some foreign leaders."
当希拉里成为国务卿时，她问她的前任之一科林·鲍威尔（Colin Powell），他是怎么处理电子邮件的。他写信给她说：“我没有黑莓。我做的是有一台连接到私人电话线的个人电脑——”听起来很古老——“这样我就能直接与广泛的朋友交流，而不必经过国务院的服务器。我甚至用它与一些外国领导人做生意。”
Powell advised her not to let the rules get too much in the way of communicating. But he also told her to be careful about using e-mail in general, as anything you write can become a matter of public record. He said all of this in an e-mail. He signed it, Love, Colin.
鲍威尔建议她不要让规则太阻碍交流。但他同时也告诉她要小心使用电子邮件，因为你写的任何东西都可能成为公共记录。他在一封邮件里说了这一切。他署名，爱你的，科林。
Powell has also said he used a secure government computer for classified information. Anyway, his solution-- checking e-mail on a desktop computer-- wouldn't work for Hillary Clinton because, again, she didn't know how to operate one. So her staff embarked on a series of thrown-together work arounds. They kept buying her the antiquated type of BlackBerry she preferred, the Curve 8310 with the trackball. One staffer remembers having to buy one either on Amazon or eBay around 2013, after BlackBerry stopped making them.
鲍威尔也说过他用安全的政府电脑处理机密信息。总之，他的解决方案——在台式电脑上查看邮件——对希拉里·克林顿来说行不通，因为，再次强调，她不知道怎么操作电脑。所以她的员工着手进行了一系列拼凑的替代方案。他们一直给她买她喜欢的过时黑莓手机，带有轨迹球的Curve 8310。一位员工记得在2013年黑莓停止生产后，不得不通过亚马逊或eBay买了一部。
To complicate matters further, her office at the State Department was in a secure area where no BlackBerrys or cell phones were allowed. The worry was that spies could remotely turn them into listening devices. So the Secretary of State would leave her BlackBerry with a guard on the way in. And then, when she needed to check an e-mail, she'd get up from her desk, go get her phone, and wander around the eighth floor balcony.
更复杂的是，她在国务院的办公室位于一个安全的区域，那里禁止使用黑莓或手机。担心的是间谍可以远程将它们变成监听设备。所以国务卿在进入时会把她的黑莓留给警卫。然后，当她需要查看邮件时，她会从桌边站起来，去拿手机，然后在八楼的阳台上走来走去。
One more quick word about Colin Powell. He sometimes used a personal e-mail address to do State business. He used his AOL account.
关于科林·鲍威尔再多说一点。他有时用私人电子邮件地址处理国家公务。他用的是他的AOL账户。
And his argument, at the time, was a personal e-mail address is basically like a home telephone line. You can make personal calls on it. And you can make business calls on it.
他当时的理由是，私人电子邮件地址基本上就像一条家庭电话线。你可以用它打私人电话。也可以用它打公务电话。
So the Secretary of State using a private e-mail account wasn't anything new. It was frowned upon by the State Department, but it wasn't forbidden. And Garrett says, reading through the FBI files, using personal e-mail for government business was also rampant.
所以国务卿使用私人电子邮箱并不是什么新鲜事。国务院对此不以为然，但并未禁止。加勒特说，阅读FBI的档案，使用个人邮箱处理政府业务也是普遍现象。
State Department workers regularly, across the board, across all levels of the organization, regularly relied on personal e-mail in order to be able to conduct the business that the State Department needed to do, because they were traveling or because it was night time or it was a weekend or they were overseas away from an embassy.
国务院的工作人员定期，全线地，在组织的所有层级，都会依赖个人电子邮箱来处理国务院需要处理的业务，因为他们在外出旅行，或者是晚上，或者周末，或者是驻扎在海外远离大使馆。
Or for a much simpler and much more important reason-- the State Department computer network didn't work very well.
或者是因为一个更简单、更重要的原因——国务院的计算机网络运行得不太好。
Part of what we learn in these FBI files is that that system actually wasn't compatible with the Wi-Fi that the Air Force uses--
我们在这些FBI文件中了解到的一部分是，该系统实际上与空军在飞机上使用的Wi-Fi不兼容——
Oh my god.
哦，我的天哪。
--on the planes that the Secretary of State travels on. So her staff would sometimes use private e-mails just when they were sitting on the plane with Hillary Clinton. People didn't think that the printer function worked very well within the State Department's regular e-mail system. So in order to print documents, they would often just forward documents to their personal Gmail or Hotmail, because it was easier to print out of that than it was to print out of the State Department e-mail system.
——在国务卿乘坐的飞机上。所以她的员工有时会直接在飞机上与希拉里·克林顿坐在一起时使用私人邮件。人们认为国务院常规邮件系统里的打印功能不太好用。所以为了打印文件，他们通常会把文件直接转发到自己的个人Gmail或Hotmail，因为从那里打印比从国务院邮件系统打印更容易。
This is one of the big, if accidental, revelations in this investigation-- just how crappy and backwards the State Department's computer system was. It's shocking for anyone who's ever worked in a normal business.
这是本次调查中一个大的（如果说是偶然的）启示——国务院的计算机系统是多么糟糕和落后。对于任何在正常企业工作过的人来说，这都是令人震惊的。
Moxt Americans would be absolutely horrified at the state of government technology writ large. But the State Department seems to be a particularly antiquated user of technology. When Colin Powell showed up at the State Department in 2001, he was given, in his office, a laptop that still relied on a 56K modem.
大多数美国人会对整个政府的技术水平感到绝对震惊。但国务院似乎是一个特别陈旧的技术用户。2001年科林·鲍威尔来到国务院时，他的办公室里配的是一台仍然依赖56K调制解调器的笔记本电脑。
If you're under 25, that was a way to dial into the internet over a phone line. And a phone line that used to-- it doesn't matter.
如果你不到25岁，那是通过电话线拨号上网的一种方式。那条电话线以前……没关系。
And Colin Powell made a really big effort to try to invest in actually putting computers on people's desks across the State Department, which did not exist in 2001.
科林·鲍威尔确实做出了很大的努力，试图投资在整个国务院员工的桌面上放置电脑，而这在2001年是不存在的。
People didn't have computers on their desks in the State Department in 2001?
2001年国务院员工桌上没有电脑？
The average State Department employee at headquarters in Washington, DC in 2001 did not have a desktop computer.
2001年华盛顿特区国务院总部的普通员工没有台式电脑。
Or any kind of computer. No laptop. Nothing.
或者任何类型的电脑。没有笔记本。什么都没有。
And Colin Powell was indeed shocked by that. So he bought 44,000 new computers. And when he would travel the world as Secretary of State, he would always sit down in embassies when he was visiting. He would find a computer, sit down, and check his own e-mail, in part as a test to see how well the organization and the embassies overseas were actually using the computers that he was giving them.
科林·鲍威尔确实对此感到震惊。所以他买了44,000台新电脑。当他作为国务卿出访世界各地时，他总是会坐进大使馆。他会找一台电脑，坐下来，查看自己的邮件，部分是为了测试该组织和海外大使馆到底有多好地利用了他提供的这些电脑。
The shame of almost all of government is that government is, in many cases, the least sophisticated technology user in American society. You see this in our nuclear missile systems, where our nuclear ICBMs in their missile silos still rely on, like, floppy disks, which the average person in America hasn't used since they played Oregon Trail in elementary school.
几乎所有政府的耻辱在于，政府在许多情况下是美国社会中技术最不精明的用户。你可以在我们的核导弹系统中看到这一点，我们的核洲际弹道导弹在发射井里仍然依赖类似软盘的东西，而美国普通人自小学玩《俄勒冈之旅》（Oregon Trail）以来就没再用过那东西了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So Hillary's staff decided that it would be easiest for her to use her personal e-mail account for everything, the e-mail that was governed by her own private server.
所以希拉里的员工决定，让她用私人电子邮箱处理一切最方便，那个受她私人服务器管理的邮箱。
It really just doesn't seem like anyone thought that deeply about this. Just, no one was really paying attention to the big picture. Collectively, Hillary Clinton's inner circle and the State Department leadership stumbled into this set up that very few people seem to have actually given any thought to the political implications of it.
真的好像没有人深入考虑过这个问题。只是，真的没有人关注大局。总的来说，希拉里·克林顿的核心圈子和国务院领导层跌跌撞撞地进入了这个设置，似乎很少有人真正考虑过它的政治含义。
Her aide, Huma Abedin, said she didn't recall any conversations about whether this was permissible. And as far as the rules for preserving e-mails under the federal laws, both Hillary and Huma told the FBI they figured any e-mails sent to an official State Department address by Hillary Clinton would be captured and preserved. They were later told, that's not how are you supposed to do it.
她的助手胡玛·阿贝丁（Huma Abedin）说，她不记得有任何关于这样做是否允许的对话。至于根据联邦法律保存电子邮件的规则，希拉里和胡玛都告诉FBI，她们认为希拉里·克林顿发送到官方国务院地址的任何电子邮件都会被捕获并保存。她们后来被告知，这不是你应该做的方式。
The main accusation against Hillary, of course, is that she set up a private server to avoid scrutiny and cover her tracks. But what the FBI investigation found was that her aides were mostly uninterested in how or where her e-mails would be preserved. Huma Abedin, who herself had an account powered by the server, told the FBI she didn't know the server existed until after Hillary left the State Department.
当然，对希拉里的主要指控是她设置了一个私人服务器来逃避审查并掩盖踪迹。但FBI的调查发现，她的助手对她的邮件如何或在哪里保存大多不感兴趣。胡玛·阿贝丁本人也有一个由该服务器支持的账户，她告诉FBI，直到希拉里离开国务院，她才知道这个服务器的存在。
Cheryl Mills, who was Hillary's chief of staff at the State Department, says she wasn't even sure she knew what a server was at that point. Which brings us to those two words you hear all the time in the coverage of E-mail-Gate-- private server. That sounds shady, right? The Clintons have a private e-mail server in their basement?
谢丽尔·米尔斯（Cheryl Mills），当时希拉里的国务院幕僚长，说她甚至不确定当时是否知道什么是服务器。这把我们带到了你在电子邮件门报道中经常听到的那两个词——私人服务器。听起来很阴暗，对吧？克林顿夫妇地下室里有个私人电子邮件服务器？
Except what that means is that they had a computer that runs their e-mails, sends and receives and stores them. Lots of small businesses have an e-mail server. This American Life has one in a closet about 15 feet from where I'm sitting. And after Bill Clinton left the White House, he basically had a small office with a staff who needed e-mail accounts. So he had an e-mail server, an old Apple machine.
除了这意味着他们有一台运行他们邮件、发送、接收并存储它们的计算机。很多小企业都有电子邮件服务器。我坐的地方15英尺外的壁橱里就有一台《美国生活》的服务器。比尔·克林顿离开白宫后，他基本上有一个带员工的小办公室，他们需要电子邮箱。所以他有一个电子邮件服务器，一台旧的苹果机器。
When you hear in the news that a server was installed in their basement just for Hillary, that's not true. A server was installed, but it was just an upgrade to the gear Bill Clinton already had for his staff. Less than a year into Hillary's tenure at the State Department, a couple of IT folks started to catch on that she was using a personal e-mail account. And there was some generalized brow-furrowing about making sure her staff was complying with the Federal Records Act, which requires all official communications be preserved.
当你听到新闻里说地下室里装了一个专门给希拉里的服务器时，那不是真的。服务器是安装了，但那只是对比尔·克林顿已有员工装备的升级。希拉里在国务院任职不到一年，几个IT人员开始发现她在用个人电子邮箱。于是出现了一些关于确保她的员工遵守《联邦记录法》（要求保存所有官方通讯）的普遍焦虑。
And it was after Hillary left office in 2013 that the trouble really started. Some Russian and Ukrainian hackers found the server and tried to break into it. They didn't succeed. But Hillary's aides were spooked. And they scrambled to secure her e-mail. They decided to change her e-mail address. But then, they worried that they'd lose all the existing messages.
是在希拉里2013年离职后，麻烦才真正开始。一些俄罗斯和乌克兰黑客发现了服务器并试图闯入。他们没有成功。但希拉里的助手们被吓坏了。他们匆忙保护她的邮件。他们决定更改她的电子邮箱地址。但随后，他们担心会丢失所有现有的信息。
It had happened in the past. When Hillary was a senator, she used an AT&T e-mail account. And AT&T didn't archive old e-mails. So whenever she got a new BlackBerry, she'd lose everything. So this time, again, it's 2013. It's up to her staff to save the e-mails, not a very complicated process.
过去发生过。希拉里担任参议员时，用的是AT&T的邮箱。AT&T不会归档旧邮件。所以每次她拿到新黑莓手机，都会丢失所有内容。所以这一次，又是2013年。保存邮件取决于她的员工，这并不是一个很复杂的过程。
But rather than give it to an IT guy, an aide named Monica Hanley grabbed a laptop from Bill Clinton's Harlem office, brought it back to her apartment. And another staffer walked her through the steps of backing up the e-mails over the phone. She backed them up to a thumb drive too. After which, she lost the thumb drive.
但与其交给IT人员，一名叫莫妮卡·汉利（Monica Hanley）的助手从比尔·克林顿的哈莱姆办公室拿了一台笔记本电脑，带回了自己的公寓。另一名员工通过电话指导她完成备份邮件的步骤。她还把邮件备份到了一个U盘里。之后，她把U盘弄丢了。
Then the server was moved out of Hillary Clinton's basement to a tech management company in New Jersey, called Platte River Networks, or PRN, as the guy who originally installed it and ran it wasn't working for Clinton anymore. Monica Hanley then tried to upload all of the e-mails she had transferred onto the laptop-- five years worth-- to the new PRN server, remotely from afar. She tried this a couple of times. But it kept not working.
然后服务器从希拉里·克林顿的地下室搬到了新泽西州一家名为Platte River Networks（或PRN）的技术管理公司，因为最初安装和运行它的那个人不再为克林顿工作了。莫妮卡·汉利随后试图远程将她转移到笔记本电脑上的所有邮件——五年的量——上传到新的PRN服务器。她试了几次。但一直无法成功。
So she ends up just FedEx-ing the whole MacBook to one of the IT staff. And then--
所以她最终只是把整个MacBook快递给了一位IT员工。然后——
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. There are e-mails on a laptop that potentially have State secrets within them that are being FedExed across the country?
等等，等等，等等，等等。笔记本电脑上有潜在的国家机密邮件，正在全国范围内被快递？
Yes. Although I don't think it seems clear that anyone involved actually thought that there were classified information inside of these e-mails.
是的。虽然我不认为有人认为参与其中的人真的认为这些邮件里包含机密信息。
But there was. At the end of 2014, the State Department made a formal request to former Secretary Clinton to hand over all of her work-related e-mails. The House Committee investigating the attack in Benghazi wanted to see them. Also, the State Department just didn't have any record of her communications while in office. Hillary and her staff handed over 30,000 e-mails, printed out, which amounted to 55,000 pages, 12 bankers boxes full of messages.
但确实有。2014年底，国务院正式要求前国务卿克林顿交出所有与工作相关的电子邮件。调查班加西袭击事件的众议院委员会想看看它们。此外，国务院确实没有任何她任职期间的通讯记录。希拉里和她的员工交出了30,000封电子邮件，打印出来，总计55,000页，12箱满满的信息。
Her legal team determined which ones were work-related by using search terms, like .gov and names of Hillary's staffers. When they were done, they asked Hillary, do you want us to keep the personal e-mails? She replied, I have no use for them anymore. So they got rid of them.
她的法律团队通过使用搜索词（如.gov和希拉里员工的名字）来确定哪些是工作相关的。完成后，他们问希拉里，你还要我们保留个人邮件吗？她回答，我不再需要它们了。所以他们就把它们处理掉了。
And this is where the narrative in the FBI interviews becomes like many other stories about Hillary Clinton, in that how you understand it depends on what you think of her. If you believe she's a sneaking, corner-cutting, conniver who does whatever she wants, this part of the story will totally convince you of that. After all, she destroys emails. But if you think she basically means well and is the focus of a seemingly endless witch hunt to pick apart every single thing she does, what she said about this in a press conference might seem entirely reasonable to you. Quote, No one wants their personal emails made public, and I think most people understand that and respect that privacy.
这就是FBI访谈中的叙述变得像许多关于希拉里·克林顿的其他故事一样的地方，你如何理解它取决于你对她的看法。如果你认为她是个鬼鬼祟祟、投机取巧、随心所欲的策划者，这部分故事会完全说服你。毕竟，她销毁了邮件。但如果你认为她基本上是好意，并且是无穷无尽的针对她的一举一动进行拆解的猎巫行动的焦点，那么她在新闻发布会上说的这番话对你来说可能完全合理。引用：“没人愿意让自己的个人邮件公开，我认为大多数人理解并尊重这种隐私。”
Hillary Clinton's team ended up deleting 33,000 messages. You've probably heard this part. Then, the FBI resurrected about half of the deleted e-mails and discovered some of them were related to her time at the State Department. But FBI Director James Comey testified to Congress that the FBI, quote, "didn't find any evidence of evil intent and intent to obstruct justice."
希拉里·克林顿的团队最终删除了33,000条信息。你可能听过这部分了。然后，FBI恢复了大约一半被删除的电子邮件，发现其中一些与她在国务院任职的时间有关。但FBI局长詹姆斯·科米向国会作证称，FBI“没有发现任何邪恶企图和妨碍司法的企图”。
In the e-mails that weren't deleted, there were 52 e-mail chains that contain information that was classified to some degree at the time there were sent. Eight of those e-mail chains contain information that was classified as Top Secret. By definition, we don't know what that information is or how damaging it might be to national security. But Garrett Graff says, a lot of times with our government, it's hard to pin down what the term "classified" even means.
在未删除的电子邮件中，有52个邮件链包含在发送时在某种程度上属于机密的信息。其中8个邮件链包含被列为“绝密”的信息。根据定义，我们不知道这些信息是什么，也不知道它们对国家安全有多大的损害。但加勒特·格拉夫说，在我们的政府中，很难确定“机密”一词到底意味着什么。
The average American, when they hear "classified information," thinks that that's a black-and-white term.
普通美国人听到“机密信息”，会认为那是一个黑白分明的词。
Right.
对。
That's binary. It is either classified, or it is not.
那是二元的。它要么是机密的，要么不是。
Right.
对。
And the government classification system is actually much messier than that. Different corners of the government may consider different things classified. Information on one day might be unclassified but might be classified on a later day, or vice versa.
而政府的分类系统实际上比这混乱得多。政府的不同部门可能认为不同的事物是机密的。同一天的信息可能是不机密的，但可能在后来的一天被归类为机密，反之亦然。
Like, retroactively classified, basically.
就像，基本上是追溯性保密。
Yeah, what in the business is called "up-classified."
是的，在业内被称为“上调密级”。
For instance, if something unclassified went to the National Security Council, someone there could decide to classify it. And that designation couldn't be changed back by someone downstream. And then, some information was classified, even though it's common knowledge. Under government secrecy law, Hillary and her top aides, discussing a New York Times article about the drone program-- that's considered a classified correspondence, because it's tacit admission that the drone program exists.
例如，如果一些非机密信息发送到了国家安全委员会，那里的某个人可能会决定将其定为机密。而该指定不能由下游的人更改回来。此外，有些信息被归类为机密，尽管它们是常识。根据政府保密法，希拉里和她的高层助手讨论《纽约时报》关于无人机计划的一篇文章——这被认为是机密通信，因为它是对无人机计划存在的默许。
Which everybody knows. Because it was in the New York Times.
每个人都知道这一点。因为那是《纽约时报》登的。
There's this one e-mail-- probably the most famous e-mail of all of them-- involving this condolence call to the East African nation of Malawi, where the president had just died. And the Vice President had taken over. And Hillary Clinton was supposed to call.
有一封邮件——大概是所有邮件中最著名的一封——涉及对东非国家马拉维的吊唁电话，那里的总统刚去世。副总统接任了。希拉里·克林顿本应打电话。
And it's this very innocuous e-mail. The line says, the purpose of call-- express condolences. And Hillary Clinton looks at that and says, I can't believe that that was actually classified. Like, that doesn't really make any sense to me.
这是一封非常无害的邮件。那行写着，通话目的——表达慰问。希拉里·克林顿看着它说，我真不敢相信那竟然被定为机密。那对我来说真的没有任何意义。
I've seen this e-mail. And it is confusing. It says "unclassified" at the top and a case number. And then, it says "classified" lower down. The innocuous part is marked with a C in parentheses, which means Confidential, the lowest of the three levels of classification the government uses. And then at the bottom, it says "unclassified" again.
我见过这封邮件。它确实令人困惑。顶部写着“非机密”和一个案件编号。然后，下面写着“机密”。无害部分标有括号中的C，意思是机密（Confidential），政府使用的三个机密级别中的最低级。然后在底部，它再次写着“非机密”。
Hillary Clinton has said she didn't know that the c in parentheses meant the paragraph was classified. Again, what you make of that depends on how you see her. Either she's lying, or she just didnt know something basic about classified materials.
希拉里·克林顿曾表示她不知道括号中的C意味着该段落是机密的。同样，你对此有何看法取决于你如何看待她。要么她在撒谎，要么她只是不知道关于机密材料的基本常识。
On Sunday, James Comey wrote to Congress saying the FBI had finished going through a whole slew of newly discovered emails. They were on a laptop that was confiscated in the investigation of Huma Abedin's husband, Anthony Wiener. Comey said nothing in the emails changed the conclusion that the FBI came to in July. That there was no criminal intent. But that Secretary Clinton and her colleagues, quote, were extremely careless in their handling of very sensitive, highly classified information.
周日，詹姆斯·科米写信给国会，称FBI已经完成了对一大批新发现邮件的审查。这些邮件是在调查胡玛·阿贝丁的丈夫安东尼·韦纳（Anthony Weiner）时没收的一台笔记本电脑上发现的。科米说，邮件中没有任何内容改变了FBI在7月份得出的结论。即没有犯罪意图。但克林顿国务卿和她的同事们“在处理极其敏感、高度机密的信息时极其粗心”。
I should mention something Garrett Graff told me a few times. He's a reporter, he said. And somewhere in the darker part of his heart, he always kind of wants to uncover some sort of wrongdoing, some juicy conspiracy. And he's almost disappointed when he doesn't. But the times that he doesn't, those turn out to be all of the times.
我应该提到加勒特·格拉夫几次告诉我的事。他说他是一名记者。在他内心的黑暗部分，他总是想揭露某种不法行为，某种有趣的阴谋。当他没有发现时，他几乎感到失望。但当他没有发现的时候，往往就是什么都没有的时候。
Well, this scandal underscores to me so much of what I have experienced in covering politics and national security for a decade. Which is, whenever you hear a government conspiracy theory, the almost universal truth is that the explanation is more likely either bureaucratic bungling or outright incompetence.
嗯，这个丑闻对我来说太强调了我报道政治和国家安全十年来的经历。那就是，每当你听到政府阴谋论时，几乎普遍的真理是，解释更有可能是官僚主义的笨拙或彻头彻尾的无能。
In a sense, this would be the easiest and most candid way Hillary Clinton could explain herself. Please forgive me. I and my staff, we just weren't that focused on my e-mails. We didn't care very much about that. We had other things to think about. Yeah, I guess it's not surprising she doesn't explain it that way.
从某种意义上说，这将是希拉里·克林顿最容易、最坦诚的解释方式。请原谅我。我和我的员工，我们只是没太关注我的邮件。我们不太关心那个。我们有其他事情要考虑。是的，我想她不那样解释并不奇怪。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC -- "CHANGE THE SUBJECT" BY THE DAN COLLINS BAND]
[音乐 -- "CHANGE THE SUBJECT" BY THE DAN COLLINS BAND]
Knowing What We Know-- so if you're following the news at all, you know that Huma Abedin, one of Hillary Clinton's top aides, is married to former congressman Anthony Weiner who just this week reportedly checked himself into a sex addiction clinic. Because after two public apologies when he was caught sending pictures of his crotch to random women online, he then went on to send a crotch shot to a 15-year-old girl and allegedly had a whole online sexual relationship with that girl.
知情——如果你一直在关注新闻，你就知道希拉里·克林顿的高级助手之一胡玛·阿贝丁嫁给了前国会议员安东尼·韦纳，据报道，就在本周，他自己住进了性瘾诊所。因为在两次公开道歉后，他被抓到在网上给随机女性发送裤裆照片，随后又给一名15岁女孩发送了裤裆照片，并据称与该女孩有了一段完整的在线性关系。
That triggered investigation. And as you probably know, his laptop and phone were seized. And then, while authorities were looking on his computer, they found e-mails between Weiner's wife, Huma Abedin, and Hillary Clinton. And those e-mails, of course, are what led the FBI to investigate another round of Clinton e-mails. And that, of course, is what led to the dramatic drop in Clinton's poll numbers and, incidentally, to Donald Trump saying, thank you, Huma. Good job, Huma.
这引发了调查。正如你可能知道的那样，他的笔记本电脑和手机被查封。然后，当当局在他的电脑上查看时，发现了韦纳的妻子胡玛·阿贝丁与希拉里·克林顿之间的电子邮件。当然，正是这些电子邮件导致FBI调查了另一轮克林顿的电子邮件。当然，这导致了克林顿民调数据的急剧下降，顺便说一句，唐纳德·特朗普说，谢谢，胡玛。干得好，胡玛。
If there's one person in the world who might understand what it's like for Huma Abedin to be a public figure and a woman repeatedly paying a public price for her husband's extramarital sex life-- she's in luck-- the one person in the world who might understand this best is probably her boss, Hillary Clinton. What is it like when they talk about this?
如果世界上有一个人可能理解胡玛·阿贝丁作为一个公众人物，一个女人为了丈夫婚外性生活而一再付出公开代价是什么感觉——她很幸运——世界上最能理解这一点的人可能是她的老板，希拉里·克林顿。她们谈论这件事时是什么样子？
OK, obviously, they're not going to do it over e-mail. This requires face-to-face conversation. This then is the conversation that we imagine they had last Friday. That's the day the news broke that Weiner's laptop-- because of his lap-- would change the focus and direction of the presidential election. Or should I say the presidential-- never mind. This, then, is the first conversation they have with that news hanging between them.
好吧，显然她们不会通过电子邮件谈论。这需要面对面的交谈。这便是我们想象中她们上周五进行的对话。那是韦纳的笔记本电脑——因为他的笔记本电脑——将改变总统选举的焦点和方向的那一天。或者我应该说总统的……没关系。这就是她们在那个新闻悬而未决的情况下进行的第一次谈话。
Huma is the first one to speak.
胡玛是第一个开口的。
I-- [DEEP SIGH].
我……[深深的叹息]。
I know.
我知道。
I know. (EXASPERATED) I know.
我知道。（愤慨地）我知道。
I know. You know.
我知道。你知道。
I know.
我知道。
You know.
你知道。
Ugh, I know.
呃，我知道。
I know.
我知道。
You know I know!
你知道我知道！
I know.
我知道。
[DEEP SIGH] Who knows.
[深深的叹息] 谁知道呢。
Hm.
嗯。
I knew.
我知道。
Mm. You knew!
嗯。你知道！
I know. I-- I didn't--
我知道。我……我没有……
I know.
我知道。
I didn't know. I didn't know-- you know, I didn't know--
我不知道。我不知道……你知道，我不知道……
I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。
Thanks for the talk.
谢谢你的谈话。
Actresses Tami Sagher and Cady Huffman playing the parts of Huma Abedin and Hillary Clinton. [MUSIC -- "ONLY YOU" BY YAZ]
女演员塔米·萨格（Tami Sagher）和凯迪·霍夫曼（Cady Huffman）分别饰演胡玛·阿贝丁和希拉里·克林顿。[音乐 -- "ONLY YOU" BY YAZ]
More coming up. Cops try to catch a squirrel in an attic and other stuff that has no national importance at all that will not affect the fate of the nation in any way, stuff we have dug up from our archives to provide a break from current events, as we head into these last days before this election. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
更多精彩即将到来。警察试图在阁楼里抓松鼠，还有其他完全没有国家重要性、不会以任何方式影响国家命运的事情，我们从档案中挖掘出来，在这次选举前的最后几天里，让我们从时事中获得喘息。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时为你带来这些内容。
And with that in mind, we have arrived at Act Three of our show. Of Mice and Men. This story is from a live show that we did on stage in New York. It's from comedian Mike Birbiglia.
考虑到这一点，我们进入了节目的第三幕。《人鼠之间》。这个故事来自我们在纽约舞台上做的现场演出。来自喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）。
I think that my favorite thing about being married is actually that you can share jokes with your wife or husband that are funny to you and that person and no one else other than, maybe, your cat. Because when you have a cat, your barometer for humor-- phh!-- out the window.
我想我结婚最喜欢的一点是，你可以和你的妻子或丈夫分享笑话，这些笑话对你和那个人来说很有趣，而对除你家猫以外的任何人来说都不好笑。因为当你养了猫时，你的幽默晴雨表——啪！——就飞出窗外了。
Last summer, my wife and I went on a trip to Massachusetts. And I called it Catsachusetts, which is not funny but, in our house, was the joke of the year. I was like, we're going to Catsachusetts! My wife is like, ahh! I was like, ahh! Our cat was like, ahh!
去年夏天，我和妻子去马萨诸塞州旅行。我叫它“猫萨诸塞州”（Catsachusetts），这并不好笑，但在我们家，这是年度笑话。我说，我们要去猫萨诸塞州！我妻子说，啊！我说，啊！我们的猫说，啊！
Everyone loves a good pun when you have a cat. And so, we drive the Catsachusetts. And when we arrive, my wife has a headache. And she asks me if I will acclimate Ivan-- that's our cat-- to the bedroom. Because you can't just put an indoor cat into a house, because he'll explode. And so, I bring in the bedroom.
当你养猫时，每个人都喜欢双关语。所以，我们开车去猫萨诸塞州。当我们到达时，我妻子头痛了。她问我是否能让伊万——那是我们的猫——适应卧室。因为你不能直接把室内猫放进房子，因为它会爆炸。所以，我把卧室安顿好。
But I'm so tired from the drive that I fall asleep, which is the only thing you cannot do when acclimating an indoor cat to a house. And so, I wake up an hour later. Ivan is gone. He got out. And so, now I'm running around the house. I'm like, my cat's going to explode.
但我开车太累了，结果睡着了，这是让室内猫适应房子时唯一不能做的事情。所以，一小时后我醒来。伊万不见了。他跑出去了。所以，现在我在屋子里跑来跑去。我在想，我的猫要爆炸了。
I wake up my wife. I say, Clo-- her name is Jen. I say, Mr. Fantastic is gone. His name's Ivan. And Clo gave me a look that I can only describe as divorce eyes. Because before that point, I was convinced that we would be married forever. And then, once I saw the divorce eyes, I was like, oh, I guess this could end. And if it ended, it would look a lot like that.
我叫醒我妻子。我说，克洛——她的名字叫詹——奇妙先生（Mr. Fantastic）不见了。他的名字叫伊万。克洛给了我一个我只能描述为“离婚眼神”的表情。因为在那之前，我一直确信我们会永远结婚。然后，一旦我看到了离婚眼神，我就想，哦，我想这可能会结束。如果它结束了，看起来会很像那样。
And so, now the two of us are running around the house. I'm like, my marriage is falling apart! My cat's going to explode! And we find Ivan. But we had another major problem in the house, which is that there were mice in the house.
所以，现在我们俩在房子里跑来跑去。我在想，我的婚姻要崩溃了！我的猫要爆炸了！我们找到了伊万。但我们屋子里还有另一个大问题，那就是屋子里有老鼠。
It was actually worse than that. Because they were parasitic mice. They have what's called toxoplasmosis, which means they have a-- yeah, you might know what this is. They have a parasite in them. And as a result, they're unafraid of cats. And they're unafraid of people.
实际上比那更糟。因为它们是寄生鼠。它们患有所谓的弓形虫病，这意味着它们有……是的，你可能知道这是什么。它们体内有一种寄生虫。结果，它们不怕猫。而且它们不怕人。
And the way we discovered this was that my wife was watching TV. And she looked next to her. And there was a mouse. And he was watching TV also. And she sees screams! And he just looked up at her like Stuart Little, like, hey, what's going on? I don't like this show either. I don't know why all those women would want to marry that one guy.
我们发现这一点的方式是我妻子在看电视。她往旁边看去。有一只老鼠。他也正在看电视。她尖叫起来！他只是像《精灵鼠小弟》（Stuart Little）一样抬头看着她，嘿，怎么了？我也不喜欢这个节目。我不知道为什么那些女人会想嫁给那一个家伙。
And then, she pushed him off the couch. And he didn't even run away. He didn't even scurry, which is a verb invented for mice. He just walked into the kitchen, like a roommate. Like, fine, I'll go in the other room. I just think you're overreacting. And then, he did a confessional into the mouse cam in the kitchen.
然后，她把他推下沙发。他甚至没有跑掉。他甚至没有“溜走”，这是专为老鼠创造的动词。他只是走进厨房，就像个室友。就像，好吧，我去别的房间。我只是觉得你反应过度了。然后，他在厨房的老鼠摄像机前进行了忏悔。
He was like, I'm not here to make friends. I'm here to win. I was here before they came. I'll be here when they're gone. I'm a mouse.
他说，我来这里不是为了交朋友。我是为了赢。在他们来之前我就在这儿了。他们走了之后我也在这儿。我是一只老鼠。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
That's The Real Mouse Lives of Catsachusetts. That night, I'm sound asleep. And my wife wakes me up by grabbing my face. She says, Mo-- my name's Mike-- Mr. Fantastic found the mouse. You need to get the mouse.
那是猫萨诸塞州的真实老鼠生活。那天晚上，我睡得正香。我妻子抓住我的脸把我叫醒。她说，莫——我的名字叫迈克——奇妙先生找到了老鼠。你需要去抓老鼠。
And I sit up. And I say, Clo. We have a cat. We do everything for the cat. We give him food. We give him an apartment that he thinks is the world. We set aside an the area in the apartment for him to poop in that we clean more often than the area where we poop.
我坐起来。我说，克洛。我们有一只猫。我们为猫做一切。我们给他食物。我们给他一个他认为是全世界的公寓。我们在公寓里拨出一个区域让他排泄，我们打扫那个区域的频率比我们排泄的区域还要高。
We have a gentleman's agreement that, in the unlikely event that a mouse should walk in that door, (MARLON BRANDO ACCENT) that he will kill that mouse. And we will never speak of that mouse again. And he will be protected.
我们达成了一个君子协定，万一哪天有老鼠走进了那扇门，（马龙·白兰度口音）他会杀了那只老鼠。我们永远不会再谈论那只老鼠。他会受到保护。
(NORMAL VOICE) That's from Catfather.
（正常声音）那是来自《教父》。
My wife says, Mo, get the mouse. And I sit up. And I see what may be the strangest tableau I will ever witness in my entire life. Ivan's smacking the mouse. The mouse flies in the air, lands, gets up, walks back towards Ivan.
我妻子说，莫，去抓老鼠。我坐起来。我看到了我一生中可能见过的最奇怪的场景。伊万在打老鼠。老鼠飞到空中，落地，站起来，走回伊万身边。
Ivan smacks the mouse! It flies in the air, lands, gets up, walks back towards Ivan. Ivan is thrilled. His toy is alive! I have a serious sleepwalking disorder. So as I'm watching this, I'm not even really sure it's happening. I'm thinking, I've had this dream before.
伊万打了老鼠！它飞到空中，落地，站起来，走回伊万身边。伊万很兴奋。他的玩具活了！我有严重的梦游障碍。所以当我看着这一幕时，我甚至不确定这是不是真的发生了。我在想，我以前做过这个梦。
My wife says, Mo, get the mouse. And she hands me a cup. I sit up. I walk towards the mouse. And the mouse walks towards me. I put the cup over the mouse. I put a magazine under the cup. I take the cup into the backyard. And I put the mouse into the forest, where I can only assume that he walked into the mouth of a wolf.
我妻子说，莫，去抓老鼠。她递给我一个杯子。我坐起来。我走向老鼠。老鼠走向我。我把杯子盖在老鼠身上。我在杯子底下放了一本杂志。我把杯子带到后院。我把老鼠放进了森林，我只能假设他走进了狼嘴里。
And from that day forward, we have called it Mousachusetts.
从那天起，我们就叫它“鼠萨诸塞州”（Mousachusetts）。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
I want to point out something really special that happened there at the end. A few minutes ago, I prefaced the story with a Massachusetts-based pun, Catsachusetts, which we all agreed, as a group, is not funny. Just moments ago, I concluded the story with another Massachusetts-based pun that was nearly identical. And that was Mousachusetts. And we applauded. Which means, in a way, it's like we're married.
我想指出最后发生的非常特别的事情。几分钟前，我以马萨诸塞州的双关语“猫萨诸塞州”为故事开场，我们大家一致认为，这不好笑。就在刚才，我以另一个几乎完全相同的马萨诸塞州双关语结束了故事。那就是“鼠萨诸塞州”。而且我们鼓掌了。这意味着，在某种程度上，就像我们结婚了一样。
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
Mike Birbiglia--
迈克·比比利亚——
I do!
我确实！
His movie Don't Think Twice is available for pre-order on iTunes. It comes out there in a week.
他的电影《Don't Think Twice》可以在iTunes上预订。一周后就会在那里发布。
[MUSIC -- "MICE!" FROM 3HREE, THE NEW MUSICAL]
[音乐 -- "MICE!" FROM 3HREE, THE NEW MUSICAL]
Squirrel Cop-- so we close our program today with this story from a police officer in a suburban community on the East Coast.
松鼠警察——所以今天我们以东海岸一个郊区社区的一名警察的故事结束我们的节目。
There was nothing, nothing going on. Saturday night in this village-- really quite, super cold. And this call came over for unknown animal in a house. And it was on my post. It was about five minutes away. So myself and another car were assigned the call. And we show up there. And luckily for me, it was another guy who was pretty new.
当时什么事都没有，什么事都没有。周六晚上在这个村庄——非常安静，超级冷。然后接到了一个关于屋里有不明动物的求助电话。就在我的管辖范围内。离那儿大约五分钟路程。所以我和另一辆车被分配到了那个电话。我们到了那里。幸运的是，那是另一个相当新的伙计。
So we walk up to the door with all our stuff on, the nylon coat, the vest, the belt, the whole nine yards. And the door opens. And the guy who is behind the door-- he's about 30. I was 23 at the time. He's about 30. He looks like a broker or a lawyer. He's just really well put together, a nice guy, wearing glasses. He's wearing these, like, silk pajamas with a monogram. Got my attention.
所以我们穿着全套装备走上门，尼龙外套、背心、腰带，全部装备。门开了。那个站在门后的人——他大约30岁。我当时23岁。他大约30岁。他看起来像个经纪人或律师。他收拾得非常得体，是个好人，戴着眼镜。他穿着那种带有字母组合的丝绸睡衣。引起了我的注意。
Wow.
哇。
And he's going, listen, I'm really sorry to bother you. Normally, I'd handle this sort of stuff on my own. But my wife really insists that I call. And so, we ask him what the problem is. He says, well, we were having kind of a romantic evening down in the living room. And we heard this scratching upstairs.
他说，听着，真的很抱歉打扰你们。通常，我会自己处理这种事情。但我妻子坚持让我打电话。所以，我们问他问题是什么。他说，嗯，我们在楼下客厅度过了一个浪漫的夜晚。然后我们听到楼上有抓挠声。
So I ran upstairs to see what it was. And it turns out it's coming from the attic. There's something up there. And it's just running around knocking a few small things over. I can't tell what it is. It could be a squirrel, a raccoon. I really don't know.
所以我跑上楼去看那是什么。结果是从阁楼传出来的。上面有什么东西。它正在四处跑，撞翻了一些小东西。我看不出那是什么。可能是松鼠、浣熊。我真的不知道。
So the other cop that I was with said, well, we really don't handle that. It's not so much a police function. But we do have numbers of these private contractors who will come in. And they'll put a humane trap down. And they'll remove the animal for you. And it's really not such a big deal. But it's really not our thing.
所以和我在一起的那个警察说，嗯，我们真的不处理那种事。这不是警察的职能。但我们确实有这些私人承包商的电话，他们会过来。他们会放一个陷阱。他们会为你移走动物。这真的没什么大不了的。但这真的不是我们的事。
So right as he was in the middle of saying that and getting us off the hook, the guy swings the door back. And there's his wife, who was just beautiful. She was beautiful. She was probably about 26 or 27 but just really beautiful, like, perfect skin, long blond hair, great teeth, brilliant blue eyes, a really nice smile. Just like beautiful and friendly.
所以就在他正要说这话并帮我们摆脱困境时，那个男人把门推开了。那是他的妻子，真是太美了。她很美。她可能大约26或27岁，但真的非常漂亮，皮肤完美，金长发，牙齿洁白，明亮的蓝眼睛，非常甜美的微笑。就像美丽又友好。
If she had said, eat this broken glass, I just would have said, OK, broken glass it is. That's fine. But she seemed really nice. So I was going to be, like, Galahad. So I just threw my arm back into this guy's chest, into my partner's chest, and I said, Mark, we can handle this.
如果她说，吃下这些碎玻璃，我只会说，好吧，碎玻璃就碎玻璃。没关系。但她看起来真的很好。所以我打算当那种加拉哈德（Galahad）式的人。所以我直接把手伸向那个伙计的胸口，伸向我搭档的胸口，我说，马克，我们可以处理这个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It'll be OK. And she was just, thank you so much. And she was really sweet. And I was, like, struck dead. So we walk inside. And she goes, I'm going to throw a pot of coffee on. And we go upstairs. We follow the man of the house upstairs. And we're underneath one of those trapdoors that goes into the attic with the staircase that folds out.
会没事的。她只是说，太谢谢你了。她真的很好。我被彻底击中了。所以我们走进里面。她说，我去煮壶咖啡。我们上楼去。我们跟着那家的男主人上楼。我们来到阁楼门底下，那是那种有折叠楼梯的阁楼门。
Right.
对。
And we do hear an animal upstairs, scratching away, just kind of scuttling around the floor. And there's definitely something up there. And it's making pretty good speed, going from one end of the roof to the other. So I reached up. And I took the trapdoor down. We unfolded the ladder.
我们的确听到楼上有动物，在抓挠，就在地板上爬来爬去。上面肯定有什么东西。它移动得很快，从屋顶这一端跑到那一端。所以我伸手。我把阁楼门拉下来。我们展开梯子。
And I have this big heavy flashlight, like, your cop flashlight, the four D-cells, the metal case, the whole thing.
我拿着这把大又重的手电筒，就是那种警用手电筒，四个D号电池，金属壳，全套家伙。
Right.
对。
And I shine it up through the hole in there. And it's pretty black. I can see the rafters, but really nothing else around there. And I start up the ladder. Now, the guy who owned the house is standing almost directly underneath me, just to the side of the ladder, looking straight up at me. And my partner is at the base of the ladder right behind me.
我透过那个洞把它照上去。上面很黑。我能看到椽子，但周围真的什么都看不到。我开始爬梯子。现在，那家房主几乎直挺挺地站在我下面，就在梯子旁边，直直地盯着我。我搭档在我后面，就在梯子底部。
So just before I stuck my head through this black hole, I just kind of paused. Like, I crunched my body up underneath. Because I'm realizing, gee, you know, I don't know where this thing is. The second we pulled down the trapdoor, all noise upstairs just ceased. So I was kind of nervous.
所以就在我把头伸进这个黑洞之前，我停顿了一下。就像，我蜷缩着身体爬进去。因为我意识到，天哪，我不知道这东西在哪儿。我们拉下阁楼门的瞬间，楼上的所有噪音就都停止了。所以我有点紧张。
And I was like, well, I look like an idiot just crouched up here on the top of the ladder. So I took the flashlight. And I just popped my head up, turned the light on again. And about six inches from the front of my face was this squirrel at eye level with me, kind of reared back on its legs. And I swear, from where I was standing, it looked like Godzilla.
我想，哎呀，我蜷在这里，梯子顶上，看起来像个白痴。所以我拿着手电筒。我只是把头伸上去，再次打开灯。离我的脸前方大约六英寸处，那只松鼠正与我平视，后腿站立。我发誓，从我站的角度看，它看起来就像哥斯拉。
It just scared the heck out of me. I thought, it's a squirrel. It's going to be hiding somewhere. It's going to be terrified of me. It was six inches away from me. And it really startled me. So I kind of went, ah! and jumped back. And the flashlight slips out of my hands. And it's heavy. And it falls directly onto the nose of the guy who's looking straight up at me.
它真的吓坏我了。我想，这只松鼠。它会躲在某个地方。它会怕我。它离我只有六英寸。它真的吓到我了。所以我喊了一声，“啊！”并向后跳。手电筒从我手中滑落。它很重。它直接掉在了直直看着我的那个男人的鼻子上。
And I don't think it broke it, but it did some damage. And his nose-- his hands up to his face. Blood just started pouring out between his hands.
我不认为它打断了鼻子，但造成了一些损伤。他的鼻子……他的手捂住脸。鲜血开始从他的指缝间涌出。
This is the homeowner?
这是房主？
This is the homeowner. I lose my balance and fall backwards, directly onto my partner. And I just pancake him. We're both on our backs. He's on his back. I'm on his stomach on my back, scuttling around like a beetle, trying to get up in this really narrow hallway. It's a mess.
这是房主。我失去平衡向后倒，直接压在我搭档身上。我像煎饼一样把他压扁了。我们都躺在背上。他仰面朝天。我在他肚子上，背朝下，像只甲壳虫一样四处爬动，试图在这个非常狭窄的走廊里站起来。真是团糟。
The squirrel, while we're floundering around in the hallway, jumps down the stairs-- boink, boink, boink-- lands on me and takes off down the stairs.
当我们在这走廊里挣扎时，松鼠跳下楼梯——咚、咚、咚——落在我身上，然后朝楼下跑去。
How undignified!
多么毫无尊严！
It was terrible. It was terrible. So we're wondering, gee, where's the squirrel? An right at that second, the woman who lived there-- you hear her scream. So my partner goes, well, we found the squirrel. It's wherever she is.
太糟糕了。太糟糕了。所以我们想，哎呀，松鼠在哪儿？就在那一刻，住在那里的那个女人——你听到她尖叫了。所以我的搭档说，嗯，我们找到松鼠了。它在哪儿她就在哪儿。
Yeah.
对。
So we go running downstairs. And the squirrel had come into the living room where they had been having their romantic evening. They had a fire going. They had pillows arranged around one corner of the couch next to the fire. And they had champagne flutes out and-- nice house, really nice. I mean, it just smelled brand new, new carpeting, new rugs, new paint. They hadn't been there for that long.
所以我们跑下楼。松鼠进了客厅，他们刚才还在那里度过浪漫夜晚。他们生了火。他们在火堆旁边的沙发角落里布置了枕头。他们拿出了香槟杯，装修很棒，真的很好。我的意思是，闻起来就像崭新的，新的地毯，新的挂毯，新的油漆。他们搬来没多久。
So the squirrel, when it bolted down the staircase, took off into the living room and ran underneath the couch for cover. So we run downstairs. This guy is bleeding all over the place on his carpets. His wife looks and says, what have you done to my husband? And I start going, oh, it was an accident. And I just stop in mid-sentence. What's the point? We've only been there about two minutes.
所以松鼠，当它冲下楼梯时，跑进客厅，躲在沙发下面。我们跑下楼。这家伙的血到处流在他地毯上。他妻子看着说，你对我丈夫做了什么？我开始说，哦，那是个意外。然后我在半句话中停住了。有什么意义呢？我们才在那儿待了两分钟。
So the squirrel is underneath the couch. And my partner is going, you know, let's get out of here. This is just not going well. So I-- I'm not beaten yet. I always have another idea. So the squirrel is under this couch, which is in the middle of the room. So I have this bright idea.
所以松鼠在沙发下。我的搭档说，你知道，我们离开这儿吧。这进展得一点都不顺利。所以我——我还没被打败呢。我总有另一个主意。所以松鼠在沙发下，沙发在房间中间。所以我有个好主意。
Why don't we move the furniture away from one of the corners and we'll put the couch in the corner. And the squirrel will probably move along with the couch, because it's the only cover available to it. And once we get it into the corner, we'll only have two open sides of the couch to worry about. So we did that.
我们把家具从一个角落移开，然后把沙发放到那个角落。松鼠很可能会跟着沙发移动，因为那是它唯一能用的遮蔽物。一旦我们把它赶进角落，我们就只需要担心沙发的两个敞开面了。所以我们就这么做了。
That is so tactical!
那太有战术了！
Yes. Yeah, I was very proud of myself at that instant. But you know, I asked her for a box. And she says, sure, we've got boxes. We just moved in. We have nothing but boxes. She runs out to the garage. And she comes back with a box. And the box is long enough and it fits across the entire short side of the couch, where the armrest would be.
是的。是的，那一刻我为自己感到非常自豪。但是，你知道，我问她要个盒子。她说，当然，我们有盒子。我们刚搬进来。我们除了盒子什么都没有。她跑向车库。她带回一个盒子。盒子足够长，刚好横跨沙发较短的那一边，就是扶手所在的位置。
So I start sweeping underneath the couch with my nightstick, trying to move the squirrel toward the box, figuring we'll capture it and just get rid of it. And we'll be out here. And there'll be no more mayhem. So it's actually working very well. And the squirrels moving down along.
所以我开始用我的警棍在沙发下扫，试图把松鼠朝盒子那边赶，心想我们抓到它就把它弄走。我们就出去了。就不会再有骚乱了。所以它实际上进展得很好。松鼠正在移动。
You can hear it. It's chittering. And I'm trying not to hurt it. I feel kind of-- I'm nervous about the thing. It might bite me. I don't want to hurt it really. It's just an animal.
你能听到它。它在尖叫。我尽量不去伤害它。我感觉……我对那东西感到紧张。它可能会咬我。我真的不想伤害它。它只是一只动物。
Right.
对。
So I'm moving it along. And everything is going very well. And then, with about eight inches to go, I took one more swipe. And the thing just bolted out from underneath the couch. It was lined with, like, tassels. I couldn't really see under the couch. It bolted out from underneath the couch and ran directly into the fireplace, which is about three feet away.
所以我把它赶走。一切都进展得很顺利。然后，只剩下八英寸了，我又扫了一下。那东西直接从沙发下面冲了出来。沙发下面镶着流苏之类的东西。我真的看不见沙发下面。它直接从沙发下冲出来，直接跑进了火炉里，大约三英尺远。
The fireplace was directly ahead of it. And it ran into the fire--
火炉就在它正前方。它跑进火里——
Oh my!
哦，天哪！
--and caught on fire and ran directly back out and directly back under the couch. (INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: What? Is it on fire? (SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER: It was on fire. Yeah, the tail, the bushy fur, the whole bit. It wasn't flaming or anything. But it was smoking. And there was a little bit of fire coming off the tail. So it runs back under the couch. And the couch catches on fire in seconds, I mean, in seconds. It must have had dust under there or something else. But it just caught on fire immediately.
——着火了，然后直接跑出来，又钻回了沙发底下。（采访者艾拉·格拉斯）什么？它着火了？（受访者警察）它着火了。是的，尾巴，毛茸茸的毛，全部都着了。虽然没有火焰之类的。但它在冒烟。而且尾巴上确实有点火。所以它跑回沙发底下。沙发几秒钟内就着火了，我的意思是，几秒钟内。沙发下面一定有灰尘或别的什么东西。但它确实立刻着火了。
And my partner and I just don't even talk. We just grab the couch, heave it upside down. And now there's plenty of oxygen for the fire to really get going. And it starts up. And we're patting it out. And it's sort of getting away from us. So we grab the only thing that's really available. And those are these really nice silk pillows. And we have one in each hand, the both of us, and we're just windmilling away at this fire on the couch. And we put it out. But it's smoking terribly.
我和我的搭档连话都不说。我们只是抓住沙发，把它掀翻。现在有充足的氧气供火势蔓延。火着起来了。我们拍打着火苗。火有点失控了。所以我们抓起唯一能用的东西。那就是那些漂亮的丝绸枕头。我们每个人手里拿一个，我们对着沙发上的火一阵狂挥。我们把火扑灭了。但沙发在冒着可怕的烟。
And it was just-- it was a disaster. The couch is upside down. The bottom of it is burnt. The house is filling with smoke from the couch. The squirrel, when it went under the couch in its death throes, just latched onto the bottom of the couch. It's like this smoking piece of gristle underneath the couch, latched on there with its claws. And were pounding, smearing it all over the place. And the smoke alarms are firing away.
这简直是一场灾难。沙发翻倒了。底部被烧焦了。房子里塞满了来自沙发的烟。松鼠，当它在垂死挣扎中钻进沙发下时，就死死抓在沙发底部。它像一块冒烟的软骨一样抓在沙发下面，爪子紧紧扣住。我们拍打着，把它 smeared 到处都是。烟雾警报器响个不停。
The guy is standing with handkerchiefs and paper towels up around his nose, which is still bleeding. His pajamas are a mess. They're covered with blood, the front of them. And we finally get the fire out. And we're both completely red, sweating. Because we're dressed for, like, zero degree weather. And it's hot there by the fire. We're mortified. The house is full of smoke.
那家伙拿着手帕和纸巾捂着鼻子，鼻子还在流血。他的睡衣一团糟。上面沾满了血，前襟都是。我们终于把火扑灭了。我们俩完全满脸通红，大汗淋漓。因为我们穿的是零度天气的衣服。而且火边很热。我们感到非常尴尬。房子里全是烟。
The wife just looks around and just starts to cry. She goes, what-- what have you done? What have you done to my house? You could see her just clicking things off on her fingers. OK, dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarms are going off. My husband's disfigured. And then, she really kind of just lost it.
妻子只是环顾四周，开始哭了起来。她说，你……你们做了什么？你们对我的房子做了什么？你可以看到她在手指上数着东西。好吧，死松鼠，毁了的枕头，需要买个新沙发。墙壁覆盖着煤烟。火警响个不停。我丈夫毁容了。然后，她真的有点崩溃了。
And he was just looking at us and shaking his head like he couldn't believe that these two idiots showed up and did this to his house over nothing really. And he just goes, you know, you really haven't done anything wrong. I can't point to any one thing that you did that I have a reason to get angry about. You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you. But I just-- I can't thank you for this.
他只是看着我们，摇着头，好像不相信这两个白痴跑来，为了一点点小事就把他的房子弄成这样。他说，你知道，你们真的没做错什么。我指不出你们做的哪件事我有理由生气。你们真的没做错什么。我的意思是，我们确实叫了你们。但我就是……我无法为此感谢你们。
They call for a squirrel. They end up with, like, $3,000, $4,000 worth of damage and a broken nose. And this is all within about five minutes. As it turned out, the squirrel-- it was a Pyrrhic victory for the squirrel. But the squirrel definitely won. The squirrel really kicked our ass.
他们为了松鼠打电话。最后造成了大约三四千美元的损失和一个断鼻子。这一切都在五分钟内发生。事实证明，那只松鼠——对松鼠来说那是皮洛士式的胜利。但那只松鼠绝对赢了。那只松鼠真的把我们打得落花流水。
(LAUGHING) That is not what you want to be saying at the end of the day.
（大笑）这可不是你希望在一天结束时说的话。
No, no.
不，不。
Could that have happened to you now 13 years later?
13年后这种情况还会发生在你身上吗？
There's always a new mistake to be made. I don't think I would make that particular mistake. I mean, you make plenty of mistakes. You make plenty of mistakes. That's just part of that job. You just try not to make the same one twice. But there's such variety that, you're going to make hundreds-- you're going to make thousands of mistakes. You're going to make thousands of mistakes until you really get a handle on what you're doing.
总有新的错误可以犯。我不认为我会再犯那同一个特定的错误。我的意思是，你会犯很多错误。你会犯很多错误。这是那份工作的一部分。你只是尽量不要犯同一个错误两次。但有太多种类的错误了，你会犯数百个……你会犯数千个错误。在你真正掌握你在做什么之前，你会犯数千个错误。
When that interview first ran on our program a long time ago, our interviewee, who asked not to be named on the radio, has now been on the force for 31 years.
当我们很久以前在节目中第一次播出那次采访时，那位要求不在广播中透露姓名的受访者，现在已经在警队工作了31年。
[MUSIC -- "ELECTION DAY" BY NOBLE SISSLE & EUBIE BLSAKE]
[音乐 -- "ELECTION DAY" BY NOBLE SISSLE & EUBIE BLSAKE]
Well, our staff-- Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivas, Sean Cole, Emily Condon, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Julie Whitaker.
嗯，我们的员工——Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivas, Sean Cole, Emily Condon, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, 和 Julie Whitaker。
Research help today from Christopher Swatela, Benjamin Fallon, and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damian Gray.
今天Christopher Swatela, Benjamin Fallon 和 Michelle Harris提供了研究帮助。Damian Gray提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
And just a little program note. We have all kinds of things on our website for the election, including daily election animated cartoons by Chris Ware and John Kuramoto. We've been posting a new one every day on our site. We're going to keep it going through the week of the election.
还有一个小小的节目说明。我们在网站上准备了关于选举的各种内容，包括Chris Ware和John Kuramoto每日更新的选举动画卡通。我们每天都在网站上发布新的。我们打算在选举周期间继续更新。
Also on our website, videos-- yes, videos-- of the songs that Leslie Odom, Jr., Neil Patrick Harris, and John Ellison Conlee did for our show, singing as, respectively, President Obama, House Speaker Paul Ryan, and RNC Chair Reince Priebus. The videos are so wonderful if you haven't seen them, I have to say, especially the Paul Ryan, Neil Patrick Harris.
同样在我们的网站上，有视频——是的，视频——Leslie Odom Jr., Neil Patrick Harris 和 John Ellison Conlee为我们节目演唱的歌曲，分别作为奥巴马总统、众议院议长保罗·瑞恩（Paul Ryan）和共和党全国委员会主席赖因斯·普里巴斯（Reince Priebus）。如果你还没看过，这些视频真是太精彩了，我不得不说，尤其是保罗·瑞恩那段，Neil Patrick Harris演得太棒了。
Also on our website-- I'm not done yet-- in response to listener demand on Twitter, true listener demand, we are also now offering MP3 downloads free of the three election songs. So OK, all of that-- the cartoons, the music videos, the MP3s-- at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Easy to remember name.
同样在我们的网站上——我还没说完——为了响应推特上听众的需求，真正的听众需求，我们现在还提供三首选举歌曲的免费MP3下载。所以好的，所有这些——卡通、音乐视频、MP3——都在我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。名字很容易记住。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thank you, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he takes our show so personally, so, so personally. He has told me, he feels like it's me and the other contributors speaking directly to him, like we were there in the room.
《美国生活》通过公共无线电交换（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他把我们的节目看得很个人，非常、非常个人化。他告诉我，他觉得是我和其他撰稿人在直接对他说话，就像我们就在房间里一样。
And at the end of every episode, he turns to his radio. And he says--
而在每一集结束时，他转动他的收音机。他说——
Thanks for the talk.
谢谢你的谈话。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC -- "SQUIRREL" BY THE WANT]
[音乐 -- "SQUIRREL" BY THE WANT]